okay let's dig into this bob woodward
holding the tapes for too long
discussion that's happening earlier in
the show i told you about the audio
taped revelations that were released
yesterday by journalist bob woodward
this is sort of part of his
uh new book release rage where he cites
a lot of these recorded conversations in
the book he also has
released many of those audio tapes and
they are shocking
donald trump knew in february that the
coronavirus was far more dangerous
than he's ever really admitted but he
was certainly downplaying it during
february
publicly saying we've got five cases
we've got 15 it will soon be zero while
privately as he said to bob woodward on
february 7th and around that time
this is very serious trump at the time
thought it was airborne trump thought it
was hitting more than just people who
were
older or sicker it is outrageous people
died as a result of how donald trump
handled this publicly many people
there's no question about it
bob woodward's investigative reporting
continues to break news
he's had an incredible career no
question
about that but the question that is
being asked is
if bob woodward had gone public with
that information months ago
instead of now to sell a book could
lives have been saved in other words
knowing in march that donald trump was
still publicly downplaying the virus
and knowing that in february privately
he had acknowledged how dangerous it was
should bob woodward have said i've got
to release these audio tapes now
because it could save lives and indeed
there is a ton of blowback against bob
woodward now arguing exactly that that
he should have blown the whistle and he
should have said listen
trump is saying something publicly i
have him on tape
saying something very different
privately some examples
john stanton the former washington
bureau chief for buzzfeed tweeted quote
there is no ethical or moral defense of
woodward's decision
to not publish these tapes as soon as
they were made if there was
any chance it could save a single life
he was obligated to do so
bob woodward put making money over his
moral and professional
duty jessica huseman a reporter for
propublica tweeted
similarly quote how differently might
trump supporters have acted if this
whole time
they knew that he knew covid was a
serious threat
woodward could have made that happen in
february jose
antonio vargas a filmmaker and former
reporter for the washington post tweeted
quote
if journalism is a public trust a trust
that has consistently eroded
and bob woodward is an associate editor
at the washington post
why did woodward sit on this information
while americans
suffered and died now bob woodward was
asked
about that exact decision in a brief
interview he did with the associated
press and bob woodward's reaction
was he needed time to ensure that donald
trump's remarks were accurate
now that sounds weird to me it's weird
to me
that for months bob woodward needed to
confirm
that coronavirus really was deadly as
donald trump told him it was on february
7th that's weird
but what would be a better counter
argument there are a few
let's examine them david moranis who's
an investigative journalist
and an associate editor at the
washington post tweeted quote
i agree completely and impuzzled by some
of the short-sighted thinking on this by
people with whom i often agree
the argument that lives might have been
saved had bob reported this earlier is
a-historical the tapes are uninvaluable
public
service another argument this is eric
wempel a washington post media critic
who said quote
if trump thought woodward i'm sorry no
this is not part of the quote eric
wempel
makes the argument that quote seeing a
lot of arguments that bob woodward did
something unethical or untoward
in holding on to his scoop about trump's
admission
that he played down the coronavirus i
disagree with the criticism
woodward is a book author and the
implicit
understanding with his sources is that
he'll interview them
interview them again and again and again
until he can stitch together
something authoritative in book form so
where do i come down on this
i believe that the strongest counter
argument
is that it is very plausible
that donald trump never would have been
interviewed by
bob woodward in other words he never
would have accepted sitting down with
bob woodward
if he had known that bob woodward was
going to publish some of this stuff
right away
i think that that's a realistic thing if
bob woodward
says i want to interview you but i might
just publish this stuff next week
trump probably refuses the interview the
pretext of accepting the interview
likely included um the the belief that
this would not be published until it
came out in a book months later
now bob woodward could have made the
decision even though my intent was not
to publish this stuff right away
this is of such public health importance
this is of such national importance
that i have to go public with this
that's something that bob woodward
could have done the question then
becomes would it actually have saved
lives
i don't know that it would have now let
me walk you through my thinking
it seems obvious if donald trump
had publicly taken the virus seriously
starting in february
rather than denying its seriousness a
lot of his followers would have taken it
more seriously
and thus fewer people would have died
that i think is true
the problem is what we're talking about
is not
trump publicly taking it more seriously
what we're talking about is
in march for example bob woodward
blowing the whistle and saying hey
trump's lying
i have him on tape i caught him
red-handed i don't believe that would
have made a difference to trump's
followers and why don't i believe that
because it hasn't made a difference so
far
trump has gotten caught red-handed doing
everything you can imagine and his
supporters by and large
have not punished him nothing happens
now we'll see in just over seven weeks
whether
in total trump is held accountable for
this disastrous four years but i have a
hard time imagining that even if bob
woodward did go public
in march with this saying whoa whoa whoa
hold on a second stop the clock
i have audio trump knows this is serious
trump would come out and just insult
everybody
kaylee magnani would have come out and
done a press briefing and come up with
some rationale for why this is not a big
deal
and then people would have moved on to
the next scandal sort of how
we are now moving on to this one from
dead soldiers or suckers and losers from
just a few days ago
so if i were bob woodward me personally
i would have come forward because i
would want to clear my own conscience
that's me
do i think it would have made a
substantive difference
i have a hard time thinking it would
have because it would be just like when
any journalist comes out with anything
about donald trump
his followers either don't believe it or
ignore it
or write it off or whatever so um
if it were me i would have come come
public because of my own conscience i
don't know that it really would have
made a difference
we're going to explore this in more
detail on the david pakman show
instagram i hope you were following us
there at david pakman show we're going
to take a quick break
and next i am going to dive into some
new policy proposals from joe biden
we will look at a very strange interview
that donald trump gave to sean hannity
last night
and so much more one of our sponsors
today is
monk pack keto granola bars and they are
giving you 20
off when you go to davidpakman.com snack
and use the coupon code pacman you know
a lot of these
uh low carb snack bars have a reputation
for not tasting great
but i can tell you from trying these
myself that that is not the case with
the monk pack
keto granola bars they taste just as
good
if not better than the sugar-filled
chewy granola
bars that many of us love but these
contain only one gram
of sugar two net carbs only 140 calories
they're completely plant-based and
gluten-free
great for anybody following a low-carb
diet
but also perfect for anybody like me
who's just trying to
reduce sugar intake which i think is a
good thing i've been working
on a box of these at home they're
delicious soft
chewy texture bunch of great flavors
including peanut butter coconut cocoa
chip which is my personal favorite it's
great for a quick breakfast
a snack in the afternoon i have been
loving these
you can get to their website by going to
davidpakman.com
snack the link is under this video and
you'll get twenty percent off when you
use the coupon code
pacman